I've never been so happy I've never been
so anxious to do the show on the morning
after a game that was a blowout hit only
5 to 6 the Baltimore Ravens trounce the
LA Rams PFC live NBC sports radio NBC SN
hello to our friends in the UK and in
Ireland enjoying the program on Sky
Sports I I I think it was the biggest
Monday Night Football coming-out party
since Randy Moss in 1998 maybe we need
to put that out there but this way for a
guy who's been around for a year now
right and we've seen him in big games we
saw him in Sunday night football against
the Patriots there was something about
last night that was magical Chris
defending NFC champions blown off the
field by Lamar Jackson and the Baltimore
Ravens it was a sight to behold
I'd say any football fan out there other
than an LA Rams fan had to be fascinated
entertained and compelled by what they
saw last night from an unstoppable
Ravens offense yeah a defense that
played much better than it will ever get
credit for right in that thrashing of
the LA Rams yeah no I mean even if
you're an LA Rams fan it'd be hard not
to just sit back and go holy cow this is
impressive this guy is impressive
I mean Lamar Jackson yeah he's kind of
can't miss football right now he's
clearly the MVP after a performance like
that and it's just it's the electricity
it's the way he handles himself it's the
confidence of him and how it has exuded
through the whole team even to even into
John Harbaugh who's you know smiling and
saying things on the sidelines you know
that they're reporting that you just
never heard before and that's what a
franchise quarterback can do and that's
what a franchise quarterback can do when
you put the right players and pieces
around him like we saw with the Patrick
mahomes last year right and it's taking
the league by storm added to the fact
that the Ravens for lack of a better
phrase you know there are one of those
bar fight teams Mike I talked about
that's what you know you get off the bus
and of all 32 teams fought each other
the Ravens are gonna be in the Final
Four if they went out in the back galley
they're gonna be there just there they
have more
bad mofos on the field than anybody else
and they just absolutely steamrolled and
bludgeon the Rams which we don't see
really in the Sean McVeigh era I'm like
I'm sitting here watching the highlights
I mean it got you're right it got you
juiced up my wife doesn't know crap
about football she was sitting there
going wow wow oh he's really good ha I
was again this is Lamar Jackson he's
pretty awesome oh this is Lamar Jackson
yeah like well you know so that just
tells you he's popping people's eyes
open that you know don't really give a
damn they're they're intrigued by what
they're saying yeah I'm so excited about
it I think I blew a fuse here in my
studio whoa he's in the dark unlike last
week when everything went it is an
improvement over last week when
everything will well at least I don't
know a temporary it's a 10 I can't see
anything my monitors off my lights are
off at least the back lights are off the
lights are still on right we'll get this
figured out we have a technician who
actually don't we stop it we stop it
last night's game to me it was just
something that and I think the lights
are gonna be back on here in a second we
do have power again it's just a matter
of time let there be light please be
like there there's light alright it was
to me just an opportunity to focus on
what the Ravens can do yeah to really
study it to appreciate it to enjoy it
it's so often gets caught up in that
cluster of games at 1 o'clock Eastern
and on a Sunday night for us we got a
lot of other stuff going on anyway no
you leave after the show but the rest of
us are still in the studio doing a bunch
of different things for me it was the
first chance I had this year to really
watch in real time as it unfolds what
Lamar Jackson plays like and looks like
and Chris here's the thing as a passer
you know I don't think we appreciate him
enough because number one he doesn't
throw the ball nearly as often as other
franchise quarterbacks he had Johnny
throws last night but but there is a
confidence to his throwing yeah you know
and and the guys covered he just zips it
in there and we just take it for granted
we it's like the guys open he wasn't
no but Lamar Jackson throw it to him and
got it between the two guys who were
otherwise standing there there's just
it's it's a and the balance it's a black
running the race yeah yeah and he's been
doing a lot of the sidearm stuff he's
been doing a lot of the home stuff and
and I I was very concerned about this
last night because it felt sacrilegious
for me to say this I think one more
Jackson right now is better than Patrick
mahomes I don't want to be a prisoner of
the moment yeah well you are you said
Kirk Cousins was so you're a prisoner of
the moment that's not what I said but I
think like right now Lamar Jackson is
better than Patrick mahomes I hate to
say it because Patrick mahomes was so
transcendent I thought there would never
be another guy that made me feel like
that well and then there's Lamar Jackson
who's already in the league and he makes
me feel like that well this guy is
transcendent I mean there's no question
about that so you're not like crazy to
say that and it's an offense that's
transcended again it's a little like the
Chiefs jumping on the scene last year
you were just like whoa what's Sammy
Watkins at Tyree killed and Kelsey and
zing zing zoom and the ball is all over
the field you know this is an attack
where we just haven't seen anything like
this in the history of the NFL it's very
creative to your point about his
throwing okay when he was coming out in
the draft there was a lot of things to
like about his throwing you know I mean
his arm is gifted you know it was it
always perfect and polished no but when
you're a natural thrower you can perfect
it and make it polished and make it look
good and when you're in an NFL you know
system and you're throwing every day in
practice and OTAs and a quarterbacks on
your butt he's he's just fine-tuned it a
little bit but the natural ability has
always been there and now we're seeing a
guy that's confident like you're saying
so he's your gosh yeah I'm feeling it
BAM sidearms just doing everything you
like that way too
and at the end of the day and I was just
telling this the stats like the stats of
Lamar Jackson are not going to tell the
beauty of him throwing the football all
the time because the beauty of him is
that he handcuffs defenses and defenses
have to worry about so many things that
he brings to the table and then
things that the offense brings to the
table around it he just when he does
drop back the throw he strikes it's like
a viper snake it's like oh okay yeah he
hasn't thrown the ball in five plays
because he just ripped off two 30-yard
runs and then all the sudden it's you
know BAM 20 yard thrower BAM just a
touchdown throw just like that so when
he does throw it it usually is were a
big play a big moment a score or
something like that yeah and think about
this yeah between the Texans last week
in the Rams last night and the Texans
are seven and four yeah and the Rams
were in the Super Bowl last year forty
one two seven and forty five to six 86
to 13 against two quality opponents and
supporting two ESPN Stats and
information that's never happened before
that a team has beaten back-to-back
opponents with winning records by 34 or
more points in both games
it's now are they peaking too soon I
don't know I don't care because it's not
gonna change as long as Lamar Jackson
stays healthy and that if that caveat
that thing that we were so obsessed with
in September hey it's fun while it lasts
but it's not gonna last it's lasted and
I don't see him take awkward hits I
don't see him take many hits but I feel
like he knows how to fall he knows how
to avoid getting himself caught in a bad
spot it's all part of the instinct that
makes him such a great athlete where and
it's the Barry Sanders Russell Wilson
know how to position your body when that
hits coming so you don't get yourself
injured but that this this really is
special and you look at the rest of
their schedule I look I don't know if
they can run the table they aren't easy
games across the board but I feel like
every game is now appointment viewing
beginning with the 49ers coming up on
Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern Game one of the
best games of the year Super Bowl 50 for
preview quite possibly between the
Ravens the 49ers and it really does feel
like I don't know on the NFC side I joke
that it it's the 49ers to own at this
point but it really does feel like it's
Ravens Patriots the only question is
who's gonna host that game right and the
Patriots if they make one false move
they're not gonna be hosting that game
no no and well you know the you know the
good thing for them is they have
a favorable schedule there schedule the
strength of it has not been nearly as
tough as the Ravens III will say that
you know I do think it's gonna be 49ers
Ravens 49ers Patriots it's one of the
two that's that's the way I feel like we
talked about yesterday the cream of the
crop right where we said you know Ravens
Patriots 49 or Seahawks New Orleans you
know I think if I had to go to the cream
of the crop of those five I would put
those three I just mentioned in there
above the other two you know I mean
again Russell Wilson and Seattle are
phenomenal but you know they've played a
lot of close games and they've won some
games that they probably should have
lost and there's nothing wrong with that
they're still really awesome and New
Orleans we've seen a few cracks in the
armor here as lately but you know one
thing I always look at for a little bit
of a stat determiner like yeah you know
me I'm not a huge stack guy all the time
that doesn't tell the whole story just
like Lamar Jackson's throwing stats
don't tell the story about how great he
is on a day to day or week to week basis
but when I look at things like overall
net points right that is a little bit of
a real indicator in the stat line for me
and I've had coaches pointed out to me
for a long long time and you go back in
history usually the top teams in
football are dominating and overall net
points and I'll just throw this out
there and that means of course I mean
you could explain that after this but
the Patriots 183 overall net points
that's the margin of victory for the
year the Ravens are 184 one more point
the 49ers are at 169 there's really
nobody even close there's nobody within
a hundred of that other than the Dallas
Cowboys and the Minnesota Vikings so
that just tells you these are three
teams that are not going out in the
field and winning but annihilating teams
at times and I think that's kind of
telling and impressive and as to the
passing statistics of Lamar Jackson
currently dak Prescott has more than
1,000 more passing yards than Lamar
Jackson but Lamar Jackson's the MVP
frontrunner and dak Prescott is on the
fringes of the conversation because it's
not how many yards you throw for it's
those moments it's the scores it's the
winds it's the dominance of the team and
being that guy who you know the
threat makes him a better passer and he
really is to bring back that Michael
Vick thing and I am serious about this I
think he is better than Mike Vick
because he puts in the work and because
and and look IO they could have tailed
him off and swim he wouldn't learn the
offense lamar jackson is the total
package Lamar Jackson gets it from top
to bottom they asked him after the game
about the chants of MVP I don't care
about MVP I'm here to win a Super Bowl
yeah that's the right attitude
he's locked in week to week he didn't
watch the 49ers game on Sunday night
because he getting ready for the Rams he
doesn't care if they're playing the
49ers next they're playing the Rams next
yeah they worry about the 49ers after
they play the Rams he's almost got that
Belichick programming in his brain and
in his being in only his second year
where he's just focused on what's next
what's next what's next with the
ultimate goal of getting to the Super
Bowl and winning it period no that's the
DNA of the patriot player right and the
Ravens have a quarterback who is wired
exactly that way and he's still just
getting started ya know what I think but
you know you're fair again his skills
are just like Michael Vick I'm not gonna
say like he you know Michael Vick was
faster than him straight away as he is
quick
I don't know alright I'll just say that
Michael Vick's arm was special but to
your other point too and Lamar Jackson's
arm is special too but Michael Vick
really has an all-time type arm but to
your other point too I totally agree
with you
where Lamar Jackson seems to be all in
on all the little things it takes to
really be successful week in and week
out where yeah Michael Vick maybe did it
a little more backyard style of football
you're exactly right Lamar does seem to
be a different animal where he is
totally focused on a day-to-day
week-to-week basis he doesn't let the
outside noise influence them and you
know we're seeing the benefits of all
that look out state difference yeah
let me tell the difference because it
ties into that run that we saw to the
goal line where he fell down got up and
almost got in right they've got the same
running ability Michael Vick used it as
a crutch when he didn't know what the
hell else to do right screw it I'll just
run sure Lamar Jackson uses it in
surgical fashion when he sees the
opening yeah and he knows it's the smart
thing to do
he does it and he's gone that's fair and
when he when he any penny
jams the pedal to the floor instantly
but it's not something that he's relying
on you know it's almost like if you're
playing Madden you got that one play
that you know is always gonna work and
if all else fails what the hell I'll
just use the one play that works right
that was Vic yeah
Lamar Jackson is hey this is just one of
many and you never know when it's gonna
happen it's gonna happen you don't know
and until then you got to worry about
everything else
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports